jury très belle année pour la france
avec le prix de la réalisation à tony
gatlif le prix du meilleur scénario
revient agnès jaoui et jean pierre bacri
pour comme une image
enfin la très belle maggie cheung reçoit
le prix d'interprétation féminine pour
le film d'olivier assayas clean
nous retrouvons michael moore dans un
instant mais d'abord le palmarès abdel
moustafa
l'américain michael moore à toutes les
filles n'en croit pas ses oreilles
après un prix à cannes il ya deux ans le
réalisateur engagé décroche cette fois
la récompense suprême avec son
documentaire anti bush après les états
unis autour de l'allier de la france par
ricochet d'être récompensé prix
d'interprétation féminine à la chinoise
maggie cheung dans le film du français
assayas tel swing junkie qui tentent de
s'en sortir pour récupérer la garde de
son enfant
c'est énorme c'est énorme énorme
cette année les français ne repartent
donc pas bredouilles les prix de la mise
en scène à taux négatif pour son film
exil et prix du scénario ou que jamie
baillie pour comme une image comédie
grinçante nouba qui incarne un écrivain
célèbre laporte avait mal fermé
non mais moi je vous demande c'est un
mot vous parlez je voulais pas prendre
le temps avec moi mais au jeu prend le
ton job non mais moi je vous le dis je
vous le dis je vous laisse pas le choix
je vous dis j'avais pas prendre le temps
avec moi dit avec personne d'autre
d'ailleurs on parle jean paul images
faciles à taux courants soyons paulino
aussi un petit mot du sud coréen old
boys grand prix spécial du jury du
thaïlandais tropical malady prix du jury
ex-aequo avec les dealers et ajoutons
pour finir que les traits côté kusturika
et wong kar-wai repartis sans rien
ou sous